as polynomial division now if you if you
missed that part or you work here but
you're like my brain is still fuzzy on
that anyway
we're gonna go back over that in the
first example so we're going to nice and
gently reintroduce you into this but for
all of these form right what we want to
say is okay you know polynomial division
it's a cool thing but usually it's a
stepping stone usually it's you do this
in order to do something else and one of
these something else's is graphic
something we're very familiar with okay
so I've provided you a bunch of cubic
functions there's no reason why we can't
increase the degree we could do to be
four or five or six or a billion if we
wanted but it's kind of like it doesn't
get more interesting it's still the same
level of complexity if you like it's
just longer okay so we're gonna have a
go at each of these for each time we're
going to divide by a given factor the
one I provided over there red and then
we're going to use that to then put
these things into a form we can actually
graph because at the moment I have no
idea what y equals x cubed minus seven X
minus six actually looks like okay
morning so let's begin by actually
writing out now first this is for
question one right our first long
division now there's a couple of
curveballs here right the first one is
I've provided you I think was X plus one
I've provided you with something to
divide by you might say well but how do
I know when I'm supposed to divide by
soon we're actually going to learn some
techniques so that you don't need to be
provided that you can actually work that
out yourself but for now we just kind of
hold your hand a little bit okay the
second thing is if you have a quick look
at this polynomial X cubed minus 7x
minus 6 there's something a little bit
sneaky in it right you don't have to
write this part down but when we do
numerical long division right if I
divided a number like this you can see
it's very important that when you're at
2041 there's a single unit there's four
tens and then there's two thousands how
many hundreds are there there are no
hundreds but it's actually very
important that you show that there are
not any hundreds that will actually
factor into our division right and it's
kind of the same deal over here you can
see how many X cubes there are you can
see how many X's there are you can see
how many constants those are how many X
Squared's are there zero of those that's
obviously going to factor in so let's
include that
when we write out our division so I'm
gonna write execute first then I've got
that many X Squared's like you told me
and then I've got minus seven X minus
six trailing okay so at this point let's
see how your recall is we're about to
start this algorithm right we've said it
all up what's the very first thing that
I do can anyone give me a suggestion
yeah
x squared okay so I'm gonna write down x
squared in a second but before I do that
we didn't expect come from and where am
I going to write it yeah go ahead Japan
I divided X cubed by X I'm like just
like in normal numerical division I'm
thinking how many times does this thing
go into whatever I'm dividing by right
so I think about how many times does X
go into X cubes and can someone tell me
why I'm ignoring the one at the moment
why am I asking you about the plus ones
yeah guy what do you write so this is
all about in polynomial division right
I've got to deal with these X's first
they're the most important for you if
you wanna think about it this way at the
moment and this is not a trick question
but it's got a weird answer what is X
equal to at this exact instant in time
what's an equal to X doesn't have any
value right X could be anything right
it's a variable that's why we put a
letter there instead of a number being
that it could be anything
X could be like a million if it were a
million then you don't care what one is
next to it this is the thing which
really takes over okay just like if I
were dividing not by 7 but by 57 it's
the 50 which is the thing you have to
really watch out for and then you
include the 7 with it so just coming
back to what if my line suggested at the
beginning I'm dividing X cubed by extra
you should be x squared what am I going
to do with that say the key tell me
where to go next what will I do with
that x squared
my kin creature for you is pay more
attention it helps when you're on time
as well okay can someone rescue Stanley
because he's gonna have to answer
another question later someone has to
say yes right I'm gonna multiply this x
squared by what I was dividing by but
what's this thing called this thing that
you're dividing by two and no it's me
it's the divisor right the guy over here
that divisor okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and multiply through and that looks to
me like I get X cubed plus X squared
happy times and you know you have done
it properly if all of your externally
match up right so I've got that what am
I gonna do with this thing yeah I'm
gonna do a subtraction to this step I'm
sort of still in the middle of my
algorithm so X cubed take my X cubed
cancels out that was the whole point of
it be careful here because you got
negatives laying around right zero x
squared takeaway x squared will give you
how many X Squared's minus one of them
yep you can tell with that this is one
of the differences between numerical low
division and polynomial long division
you don't have negatives flying
everywhere when you do this okay which
you never got when you're dividing
regular numbers okay
I'm then going to do the next step
what's the next step okay I bring down
the 7x and now I'm ready to go again
just like I was at the start I've kind
of completed one cycle okay so I'm gonna
ask just like I did before how many
times does X go into that guy minus x
times right which is weird to say but
you know that you've got this right if
when you multiply background you're
going to get something with your kettles
down here yeah so I'm going to multiply
X plus 1 by minus X sorry to interrupt
all right we're multiplying a prefer not
on a second yet yep so I'm gonna get
next squared but what's gonna be at the
front is giving you - thank you very
much that's the whole point there and
there - minus X yeah so many
coefficients and pretty much flying out
it is hard to keep it straight but at
this point I don't know what this looks
like I'm gonna do my subtraction now
right did I did I wrench it before
there's gonna be a lot of [ __ ] right
you'll you've got two negatives and
you're
tracking them okay what doesn't care too
loud so what am i doing
yeah that's exactly right that's so
confusing I'm gonna write it down to
maybe I encourage you to do so as well I
feel like way that's weird right what
you're doing in this line is minus
x-squared and you're subtracting minus x
squared when you subtract something from
itself maybe I could do it that's a
little more obvious right you get zero
don't you which is sort of what we want
it's always supposed to go to zero so
this guy's gonna cancel out what about
this be careful it's by 2 7 X minus
minus X so how many X's we're gonna have
minus 6 X right so when you do that
double negative rule really you're
adding X so you got one more than there
I'm fine
I'm gonna carry down this minus 6 and
I'm at my last step what do I do
Seiler you want to redeem yourself here
okay I'm gonna write minus 6 or am i
doing that where am I putting minus 6 on
the top by the way on the top what is
that thing on the top that we are
building does anyone know its name
starts with Q that's the question thank
you very much
so there's my question and I'm pretty
much on the homestretch what am I gonna
do with that minus 6 this is our last
step through the algorithm okay good
multiply back by the divisor by the way
this is why I was pointing out the names
of these things right
is it it's so much more efficient to say
multiply by the divisor rather than
multiply by that thing at the front you
know the one that I'm talking about it's
like what don't be ambiguous give it a
name so you can talk about it okay I'm
gonna multiply out the front when you
multiply by negative six
what do you get more playing this by
negative six so one owe me up yeah mine
negative 6x minus six and so you know
Miss at this point mr. Wu is relieved
because you gave you the right factor at
the beginning because what's gonna
happen here they're all gonna kid so
what's this number down here to zero
when you get to the end of your you know
your division that's that remainder that
you get at the end so you would write
like remainder whatever
right left remainder three or minute
four
but yeah if you get a remainder of zero
right that means that there's nothing
left over so you've divided in nice and
neatly so a remainder of zero I don't
have to worry about that which is great
okay one last thing right we talked
about divisor quotient remainder this
thing you were actually dividing the
thing you started with anyone know its
name it also starts with the date it's
very close to this thing um this
original function you begin with it's a
thing that you've yeah now this is an
economics word right well actually it's
our word economics borrowed it because
when you've got a thing and you're
dividing it out into lots of people
that's say that's what we mean by a
dividend right so this is the thing that
you are is being divided just like in
the stock market got some profits it's
like it's handout those dividends okay
so that's the thing that's being divided
all right